computers have beaten us at our own
games checkers chess Scrabble jeopardy
but there is one game that a computer
could never beat go inside the Four
Seasons Hotel in downtown Seoul Google
is trying to change that by challenging
one of the world's top go players Lisa
Dole go is simply put complex in chess
there 20 possible moves per turn but go
it's about 200 go players base moves on
what the board looks like how it feels
to win the machine must reproduce the
magic of human intuition
alphago system uses deep neural networks
which approximate the web of neurons in
the human brain basically if you feed it
enough go moves from the world's
grandmasters it can learn to play a go
and play it well this contest tests the
progress of modern AI and measures its
potential to rapidly reinvent everything
from internet search engines and digital
assistants to robotics and scientific
research no matter whether the machine
or the human prevails it's still a win
for Google and the future of artificial
intelligence a future where machines can
truly teach themselves to improve
you